hey
[Music]
I think we should be good
and we're live
gamer
what's up howdy the cat how's it going
looks like you're the first one here so
you can tell me if my uh
any of my stuff is bad
audio wise
foreign
everything's good great to hear
I'm just sharing out on Twitter that I'm
live
because I don't do a lot this is just a
it's just an image
what
okay that didn't work
what's up nuke do
there we go that's the actual stream
link
all right there we go
all right everybody excited for the game
awards and winner time very much so
I don't live in a place that gets too
wintry in terms of like snow but I
always like the winter I grew up with
snow so it was based and uh
yeah game awards should be lit I was
like a game awards when are the game
awards
I always like
forget about them whenever they are and
then it's like
the day of I see people talking about on
Twitter and then it's it's go time
what do you think about the Dead Space
remake they're working on I actually
never got into Dead Space because it was
too scary for my little 12 year old uh
brain so I played like the Dead Space 2
demo and I
that was it for me so
but I saw that in the Calisto project is
the thing like dead space right
um so I think both look good I really
don't have enough details
um
about the Remake to have an informed
opinion to any degree
December 8th okay so early December I'm
still a month out so I haven't forgotten
it too much or haven't been caught off
guard too much by it that's good here
all right so just probably gonna repeat
this a couple times but starting out the
stream obviously I don't stream much but
I figured since there's obviously not a
video this week that I would uh do a
stream since I do want to stream just
like in general
I feel like I should stream and uh
yeah so I thought it would be a good uh
thing to do while I'm making my next
video could do a little bit of research
for the video and just stream it and let
you all see a little bit of the process
really hope Elden ring gets Game of the
Year and I hope the DLC trailer gets
released I honestly if Elder ring didn't
get game of the year like not much skin
off my back but yes the DLC trailer like
if I could trade uh goatee for getting
the DLC trailer and getting a DLC here
sooner I of course would
um
but obviously I think it's really good
game and I think it's just going to come
down to
uh Elden ring and God of War Ragnarok
but that's probably not a very
controversial opinion but it's just
which one you think it's going to be
though only like journalists and
creators have played Ragnarok I haven't
um so we have to wait and actually play
it to see
I really think you deserve much more
attention thanks I appreciate it that's
kind
December 8th it said big sword yeah this
was a I went back in my files and I saw
I didn't have a build of the game since
uh like I hadn't actually played the
game not modded at all
um since I did my new game plus guts run
through
for sure ER has it in the bag maybe I've
seen a good amount of people being like
ooh God of War Ragnarok it's gonna it's
gonna take it down and it does have like
a maybe more immediately General
audience Elden ring ended up getting a
lot more of a general audience than
maybe expected
um or the other Souls games had but
I would trade two vatis one zero storm
and one and a half of you for deals a c
trailer
well I don't know if to feel that that
makes us worthwhile because we're equal
to some aspect of the DLC or bad that we
can be traded in for a trailer but uh
yeah I know I would uh
the actual content in the game is always
uh
more lit oh I forgot you get the
inverter Hawk heater Shield here it's
always more lit than the content around
it the only reason the content around it
is big is because the content itself is
so cool
well yeah we're just gonna be running
around
um I'm gonna be looking at the subject
of the next lore video maybe reading
item descriptions maybe end up I'll just
end up playing around a bit um on this
character or another
um if we're just hanging out
um
could possibly play a different game but
that's only I'll probably see how
everyone's feeling
um later in the Stream but for now it's
all just Elden ring
so they did make a video on it let's
look at the inverter Hawk heater Shield
Eldon ring came out it was all over my
recommended on YouTube and God of War
Ragnarok came out nothing was on like
while I was wreck nothing was on that
recommended it I'm assuming didn't mean
to say it or white okay
nothing was on recommended oh okay I
gotcha I got you
um but technically God of War isn't out
right or did you mean when out when
Alden ring was coming out
um you got all the people
uh or you got all the YouTube
recommended
um so technically the release they
forgot of war is sometime this upcoming
week right or like the ninth or
something
um
so would that allow you any more time
for it to get similar
I feel like it's going to be similar on
how God of War 2018 got goatee over Red
Dead 2 back in 2018
yeah maybe
um in the sense of God of War gets it
again over Elden ring I've seen a good
amount of comments of people that were
base since I recently played through God
of War the original or the 2018 since I
had never played it and it was uh it was
really good
um but I saw a lot of like when I looked
at discussion of it
um
it was very much there was a lot of
people talking about the goatee with red
dead two people have been like Reddit
too was great should have gotten it or
read the two wasn't as good enough to
um God of War but
so people were going either way on it
I'm sure whatever it gets either in the
game awards or Publications give
which one Gody people are going to have
the same kinds of discussions of some
people like one or the other and they're
gonna say it should have gotten goatee
basically because I like it more but
because I like it more for X reasons
God of War so regular though at least
I'm um
um what's up Donnie days uh I guess
somewhat um I see how it's
I don't want to say formulaic it's a
little some of the open World
quote-unquote open world quote unquote
RPG elements were somewhat formulaic
um and it's someone regular but the
overall like experience of the game I
think is just a really fantastically
done game
um
like the just the experience of playing
it going through the world narratively
and then also like having really fun uh
gameplay combat even if the open world
or like the exploring stuff got tedious
for me after a Time
um but yeah this was one of the if any
of you saw my if any of you didn't see
my
was it my previous video or my two
videos ago uh the video on the Fallen
Hawks Fallen Hawks this is one of the
shields they bear the inverted Hawk
heater Shield
um inverted Hawk is the emblem of the
company of slaves ordered to explore the
Eternal City this item gave a lot of
good insight
specifying how the company was slaves
they weren't just adventurers and that
they were ordered to explore the Eternal
City and of course there's the the hawk
that gets them connected with stormvale
um by most people I think or in my eyes
it's a strong Stormville connection
um
yeah
God of War isn't that unique Eldon ring
has so much better story and all the
items in Eldon ring and how the they
have all descriptions in crazy funny you
see from soft get two goatee Awards in a
row since sekiro uh yeah like obviously
it's a little bit
um anybody can give anything go to like
uh I saw a comment talking to how far
Far Cry 6 had a goatee Edition
um
he has like one publication gave them
the award
um so
yeah but I guess things like the game
awards are what people use as like a big
standard
um
and we'll see what happens in terms of
like Eldon Rings definitely story or
lore or that kind of World building is a
lot deeper
um than the lore or like building of God
of War even though obviously God of War
has a real mythology behind it there's
just not as much or at least when I went
through the game even with the lore
notes that you get
um as you unlock things I would read all
the lore notes but it's not as in-depth
as this because it is a much more story
forward game I will say uh
that I think
I was gonna say about this story oh I
don't know I feel like a lot of people
in the community are pretty pretty happy
maybe not happy they're pretty a lot of
times they have positive things to say
or the lore Community has positive
things to say about
um the story and I'm gonna be honest I'm
uh I think most
from soft stories are pretty meh um like
even Elden ring there's not enough going
on in the game in terms of motivations
in terms of character development that
for me to be like this is a really good
story in the game if that makes sense I
still think the World building and
there's is really good and there's a lot
of really strong story elements
especially through the lore and the
character building of the characters as
we come to learn about them through the
items of lore and their uh the stories
that they've lived to get to the point
of the game but a lot of times in the
game it feels like there's not as much
of that because we always get to the
world after it's decayed after all the
cool things have happened and then we do
our own cool things which is just kind
of mopping it up
um let me know if that makes sense
how long before we get a video on who
turned Bach into a tree someone did my
boy dirty and I want to know who
um what's up James Lange language
um I actually I don't know if it was
just because when I first played through
the game
um I never met Bach and I think he was
one of the ones that had a no I'm almost
positive he was one of the NPCs that had
a super glitched
um NPC questline storyline
um so I first played through I never
really interacted with him much and or
he might not have been in the game at
all and then my afterward playthroughs I
just never I know I never did his quest
so I've actually never done the botquest
um
but I'm pretty sure doesn't he kind of
mention his first lines that
um no actually maybe not I know he ran
away from the I mean human Chiefs right
uh or he ran away from the cave maybe
they didn't turn him into magic or maybe
they did because the Demi humans do have
some basic magic
um or maybe the Chiefs don't and then
only the queen does I forget uh what's
what on that one
how'd he said kill it three times four
times actually so let's kill one
require materials to kiss turbo just to
kiss herbas well we've gotten so many of
those and they are picking they're
picking The Duchess herbos
um
I think that sounds weird to pronounced
but I'm pretty sure I'm pronouncing it
right
um let's read the description on that
and I still haven't gotten to the actual
subject of
an explore video uh since I was gonna
just be walking around that
um in this video and like exploring and
taking notes this was just going to be
uh me getting lore notes and I decided
to turn it into a stream
but first do Coast Urban so we have the
normal Urban
just just an herb
very common medicinal plant can be found
in thickets and elsewhere Evergreen
leaves that give off a faint light
interesting that there are leaves that
give off a light they have a little bit
of the light of Grace maybe material
used for crafting items
and the Duke is Turbo a herb that grows
in the false night in and around the
Eternal City material used for crafting
items soaked in Arcane do gives off the
faint glow of Starlight
which is a again we have a little bit of
difference we can see the dew on The
Duchess Urban
um which makes sense it's called do
kissed otherwise they are the what looks
to be the the exact same
image template um just color differently
and imbued with
do
um one is the lights the air tree above
ground the other is the same but
Starlight Darkness underground and
eternal cities
um
last night in and around
something I actually don't know anything
about is like the long history of the
false Knights and if the ancestral
followers have uh
where they kind of were they ran down
here to escape the herd tree uh or this
is what where they always were and they
always had some form of ancient night
that's actually something I'm pretty uh
without knowledge of completely on the
lore aspect
and these guys do they have
they have any is this just what how they
look like or are they gonna no that's
just their fur I thought they had some
polyps on them
James says I missed him too my first
month was in 1.0 yeah so my first
playthrough wait was 1.0
um
1.0 was like before release No or do you
mean you went back and played it in 1.0
or you uh
you mean you played on like whatever the
release was missing two first
playthrough he just says some someone
named Cloud turned him into a tree I'm
sure there's no lore there but it's
always bugged me that there could be
something in that in the
um I guess now unused voice lines I
could look that up uh and see if there's
anything about that in the I guess like
total voice lines in the game
I had no internet oh original release
very interesting yeah um I didn't hear
the cloud thing so that's something to
look into especially if I ever did a
video on Bach for sure
that would be a
a strong Avenue to look into
kyode says what's up Gamers what's up
kid Donna PK EOD don't know how you
pronounce your name but I'm not hoping
it's something like what I just did
all right well uh now let's let's get a
little bit into the actual lore
um if anybody who's gotten here late I
am just doing a stream about uh lore and
about goatee discussion a little bit
um because I obviously didn't have a
lore video out today uh or this week so
I'm just gonna so I figured I'd do a
stream and do a little bit of lore
hunting for my next video as a stream so
there's a little bit of uh content in
that way
and the next video is going to be you
could maybe tell from the thumbnail if
you look closely is gonna have a lot to
do with these guys
which you might not know but they're
actually uh an enemy they're not they're
not just a like spell or spell-like
thing they are an enemy of some kind
um the internal file names call them
wisps
or just a wisp one is a wisp and then if
you want to pluralize that it'd be wisps
and yeah there's a couple interesting
things about them and mostly it's going
to be lots of speculation about what
they are and uh
and what they're doing who they're
connected to all that kind of thing
that's just basically just going to be
um the video it's gonna be one of the
least lore enemy this is actually
probably
at least up to this point what I found
the enemy With the Enemy with the least
lore in the game because even like the
uh
what were they called I can't I got the
name for them the mihari ishi the
lookout Stones they had an item drop
they weren't referenced by anything in
the game but they had their own page in
the game guide I don't think I don't
have the game guide I don't think these
have their own page
um they don't drop anything they're
untargetable they're I think they're
Invincible
um regardless of being untargetable so
you can't damage them in any way
um if I was Elite hacks or coder man or
I could if I could just use a debug menu
um they would I could see more about if
there's any way to give myself some sort
of perms or ability to attack them but I
don't uh have those abilities so we're
gonna say they're basically Invincible
we're gonna say they're invincible and
untargetable and that there's nothing we
can do to change that and they're they
don't give any drop because
you can't kill them and they kill
themselves or they wean themselves out
um but
uh yeah they can't be killed but we can
see them
um in action petering themselves out if
I turn my uh invisibility off right now
I have it set so none of the enemies see
me in case you didn't notice uh I can
walk up to anybody and we're we're
pretty chill
chill with the crab share with these
guys these guys are also one of the most
hated enemies in the game as they are
quite the uh the shock to a new player
who just gets down to the show for a
well and is running around getting shot
at by The ancestral followers with the
bows
but it's a
yeah no that's that's it they're they're
a shock they're pretty frustrating
because there's basically no way to deal
with them you have to get away from one
of those get away from them uh John C
says I was one of those I'm assuming you
mean one of the players who got shocked
by these guys uh which I was too I'm
pretty sure they killed me at least once
maybe twice in the first run in
chauffeur uh they and yeah it's just
that and the long super long range super
quick arrows from the uh archers
definitely makes uh going through here
pretty hectic sometimes it can get a bit
trivialized by a torrent because you can
end up just zooming past everything
pretty well even if you have low Health
that's kind of what I did the first my
first run
um and I found most I found all the
pillars and I got the boss unlocked
probably before I was ready and then I
maybe fought the boss once but then
peaced out
um so yeah that's a an issue with
torrent that comes across in a lot of
the open world segments is sometimes
trivializing uh things that would
otherwise just be quite the Monumental
task to deal with to get through to pass
through to find a hidden way to not take
a lot of damage while getting through
James says I assume those are will have
the Wisp shofar being a reference to the
phalans I assume everything here is a
fairy connection uh that is really good
um I've heard about the fair connections
and fail and somewhat I don't actually
know what the phalans are
um other than I assume something in
Norse and or Celtic mythology
um but yes the connection to fairies is
very uh
visible and they as I said they're
called the Wisp in the file name which
definitely very obviously connects to
will of the Wisps and that is something
I'm going to talk about in the video the
will of the Wisps or the will of the
Wisp
um
because these guys are a uh if not a
direct reference to that and to that
misleading light
um I could probably pull pull in a
connection about them being a misleading
light since they look like something
interesting they do look decently enough
dangerous with the electricity that most
players just off game design will
probably know they're somewhat
um
somewhat of a dangerous being but yeah
they definitely uh have a little bit of
the appearance appearance of the willow
wisp and that'll be something to talk
about in the vid kind of look like blue
or electric version of the orb that you
crack on your chest when you use a roon
item to get rooms
well they definitely look like an orb
with a light in the center but beyond
that I don't really remember what the
orbs look like so let me uh crack an orb
golden Rune let's do a golden Rune six
they have the
central circle in the middle and then
kind of wisps out
um that form the Outer Circle kind of
like a atom like a nucleus of an atom an
electron cloud
Grace that dwells within the inhabitants
of the lands between the lingering
residue of gold use the gain 2000 runes
those born at the foot of the earth tree
are blessed at least that is the
enduring belief of the people of the
plateau that's interesting they all
reference the at least these ones
reference the
uh alto's Plateau maybe that's because
you kind of get these runes when you're
in the Altus Plateau area I never really
uh caught that
you see the Earth tree towering over
okay maybe they all have little notes
provided a finger made and can be found
yeah oh that's cute I never noticed that
um that all of the
runes
um maybe I should actually read item
descriptions more often um that all of
the runes have like notes that are kind
of correspond or correspond to the areas
in which you're gonna find them in so
these early runes you find them early in
the game finding a finger Maiden
probably before you meet Melina and then
the higher runes you still you see the
archery
um you get to the outlets Plateau you
get the plateau notes the grace of gold
bless those who refers to serve it with
the most Vivid coloration
um the first to serve it I don't
actually know who that's in reference to
then the Newman since you find these uh
a lot of the times I want to say well
around the Newman maybe um but also I
feel like the the ants low in the
darkest deeper depths do you get the
Newman runes from them as well not just
human Heroes Rune I feel like you got
Newman's Rune from there
trophy means fairy or something in Old
Celtic I found out that the Ansel river
is a reference to short story called me
and cell which means my own self I think
it might be relevant to Ronnie that very
well could be I know I think zeostorm
had a good video about the Celtic
mythology
um references in the game so maybe I
should go give that a re-watch see all
the references he com he has compiled
um
because I know he did a lot of uh a lot
of Celtic stuff and I actually yeah the
chauffeur
um
definitely could mean Feria I don't know
I didn't know what it meant but I knew
that it was uh definitely seems like an
Irish word I had one of my uh Irish
friends tell me how to pronounce it and
I've gotten a couple flame War comments
um correcting my pronunciation and I'm
like hey I'm not choosing which Irish
person to base this pronunciation off of
so I'm just gonna go with the person I
know in real life not random internet
commenter
you get Newman runes from the sacks of
fat ants if you pop the sack before
killing the ant yeah yeah that's what I
was uh referencing
um
so you put it in more eloquent words
than I
um okay so this was all just because I
wanted to use one of these so let's use
one
well the little particle effects when
you bring it out is definitely similar
to the particle effects of white on this
again we get a gold silver
um or blue dichotomy gold the Runes of
the herd tree versus the
below the
underground the Newman the fake sky it's
very blue it's very silver
um it's another another dichotomy
shiofra is what I go with I haven't seen
that all to watch it yet I'll definitely
um recommend it a lot of the
uh zeostorm does a lot of news coverage
and then also we'll cover the different
kinds of influences and theories like
you did I think he did one for Christian
influences which there are definitely a
lot
um he did one for Celtic mythology
influences I'm pretty sure I'm like 98
sure he did a video on that
um so definitely worth a watch and a
re-watch for me
it's weird how these guys don't show up
anywhere else at all except here in
consecrated snow field if I recall yeah
I was gonna um go to consecrated snow
fields sometime later in the Stream
um I'm gonna explore them here and then
explore them in consecrated you get the
ancestral followers uh in the same place
too I think there's one or two other
places The ancestral followers show up
um
well they show up in liernia right and I
don't think there are any of these orbs
uh in leernia
um maybe the
archery has too much of a presence there
whereas the consecrated snow field is
pretty hidden so even though it's above
ground it's a secret area it's the
entrance to the Hallock tree it's
covered in snow so there's a lot more
coverage and blanket from the ER
training and the influence of the earth
tree so that's going to be something
that could uh justify why they're here
underground where your tree can't see
them and then in the consecrated snow
field but not anywhere else with the
ancestral followers like in liernia
message retracted oh I can catch it one
guy in the lake of rot element like what
um
yeah there's the The ancestral follower
right that is a place of wool ruins
um
so there's a little bit of justification
uh for them to be there but and like you
also see a dragon king Soldier so like a
slight connection but yeah it's pretty
pretty crazy to have them that present
in there so the lake of rot is
definitely a weird Confluence of places
in general
and I said a while ago I was gonna have
these guys shoot me so let me uh do that
this should hopefully not
damage the stream at all let's make sure
yeah
um
since I just all tabbed out to turn off
my invisibility
all right no longer always stealth so
let's see uh they already shot me
no not yet
all right is everyone ready for uh
electric balls to shoot me I should
still be invincible so we shouldn't die
but I should also have enough Health to
probably take it but
oh there we go
one two three four five six
and then it pieces out it does have a
little sound
um when it pieces out
um
let's listen for that again smoking
Bob's hey mate everything well hey
smoking uh yeah everything's great uh we
just got into the stream I'm doing on
I'm doing a stream because I didn't do a
lore video obviously uh for the week and
so I'm doing it was doing some research
for lore I figured why not stream it so
they do want to stream a little bit more
since I haven't streamed since like
before Elder ring came out
maybe I won't stream all the time on
this channel
um but for now I did that one poll and
everyone said yeah do it on the channel
so uh that's what we're doing
and I'm just gonna
turn my sound effects volume up
this shouldn't be too this might be a
little too loud
let's bring this down a little bit
um just so we can hear the lightning on
the little ball and listen for the sound
it makes when it dissolves let me know
if any of you uh
let me know if any of you recognize the
sound from anywhere and this isn't like
a me leading up to something I'd never
noticed the sound before so this is the
lore Research In Action cool surprise to
you streaming hot yeah
um I just I should stream more just
because it's uh I'm playing the game so
why not
um
but yeah I'm happy that happy to have
you happy to have it everyone that's
here I'm just hanging out by banana
Sunday afternoon
all right listen up
one two three four five six
yeah like a very fairy
um
so I can't think what that sounds like I
want to say it sounds like something in
the game like maybe a summoning thing
um
Chimes and stuff but I can't
I can't say for certain so if any of you
um
have any idea what that sounds like feel
free to lay down and chat
mushroom that grows in the false night
in and around the Eternal City
it drips with a viscous fluid that
behaves much like oil
I believe there's something in there
about the albanyerex but I don't uh
nothing that seems like it would give
any more information on our wisps
sounds like the consumption of maroon
items oh well if it looks like it then
that would uh make sense that it sounds
like it all right I'm going to eat a
rune and then I'm gonna run over and do
it again so we'll see we'll see Ethan
Washington that's uh that's correct
yeah we're talking about ruin items yeah
well that's basically
maybe the sound of consuming a
remembrance oh okay well we can try
we'll try first the normal Rune then
I'll run up to it and then maybe we'll
try a remembrance
all right normal room
golden Rune seven
okay the Chimes when you start with it
are pretty similar Let's uh
try again
okay
now let's do a remembrance
okay remembrance has more of the floaty
things at the end but otherwise I feel
like you'll remember it sounds pretty
similar to a knot remembrance I think
larger runes remembrance make a
different noise
um
only high pitched
it's like a different note on the same
instruments
yeah it could be
the same kind of uh chime
maybe not liar but
I'm just gonna keep listening
you can do a Newman's room
oh I was definitely quieter than uh
then scar Serge radon
um
I also never noticed what looks like
crystals showing up
um
are the runes supposed to be crystals I
thought they were basically ethereal
completely but you can see crystals
spread out
a little bit or what look like crystals
all right well let's go get ourselves
killed by another not get ourselves
killed let's go have another one of the
Wisps kill themselves on us
and let's see
all right
could Sarah please shoot me
yeah it does sound a little bit like the
a different note on the same instrument
um though like I'm like relatively
musically inclined but I don't know that
much about different
um chime like instruments
or Bells
um
or video what is the origin of the lanes
between grass hmm yeah that's a that's a
tough one
I think it would just be uh the greater
will created divisions and then
Evolution happened and grass eventually
showed up
when the insects disappear
only high-pitched when the insects
disappear
I don't know nuke do what do you mean by
when the insects disappear
like when the the Newman
the Newman ant insects
oh
yeah that's what I meant when I said
that using the Rune items made it look
like you were holding a little orb that
would then shatter kind of like
Ronaldo's orb shield in her first phase
oh yeah and that's true
yeah
and we could also it's always a fight in
lore
um how much is something a reused assets
or a aspect of development and how much
is it an aspect of lore and while
aspects of development
um and like simple real constraints can
be make themselves into lore it's always
good to have some awareness of what
you're thinking about when it comes to
that
it's like the droning part of the
remembrance room noise is brought to the
focus of the sound for the electro orbs
and lingers on for a second I could be
um definitely and then it sounds more
developmental because I just don't know
what connection I would be able to draw
from like that specific reworking of one
sound to the other
um except maybe just to think of those
electric the will of the Wisps kind of
in the way of being a spirit a wisp a
fairy
um something like the orbs
um for the ancestral followers I guess
maybe
if we tried finger butthole wow comedic
the true
the true comedic Genius of the from soft
Community will uh never go away
we will forever have that
I'm glad thank you for uh
bringing it back moose Campbell
insects that carry the ash four oh oh
okay
definitely think it's coincidence they
sound similar though yeah Ethan um again
that's what I was saying with the
development lore stuff and good stretch
and make a connection while also just
being aware of how it probably comes
from that
foreign
okay
I don't know no I think I still die from
Fall damage no you don't die because
you're just jumping off this got it
um
sounds exact time of the scarabs
disappearing yeah
okay well now I need to go find a scare
oh no you do take oh no that was the
really good mixed up here with fall
damage does anybody know where a Scarab
is on this
on this level
well good call on nuke everyone uh
jogging everyone's memory
there are plenty to the east
to the east like this way
I remember I can imagine one in my head
I think a red one either a red one or a
miracle one
um I want to say near the dragonkin
soldier
we can try hearing one more of the
electro orbs just to have that to go
with us
further theater lots of scarabs at the
foot of the minor herd tree at the top
oh oh true
that is true could go there
by the elevator on the far side
all right well I'll go to The Far Side
all right shoot me
shoot me
I am thinking it sounds like the scarabs
hey howdy the entire next video might be
about those blue balls
um
but no the string might not necessarily
just be about them I was doing some lore
research
um talked a little bit about the goatee
stuff talk a little bit more about it
later
um it's also the connection of the
um
of those orbs to the ancestral
uh worshipers followers and just the
whole area in general them versus the
Earth tree
all right
okay let's vote um I don't know if I can
do a poll
I probably can let's see let me see real
quick if I can
do a quick poll
highlight stream I don't know
no oh create a poll
all right
kill or let's gonna do a poll on whether
I should kill the beetle or let it
disappear
since it does disappear when it dies
right
yo
disappear the spelling disappear wrong
and hey before everyone gets gets gets
on my case about a whole uh disappear
first okay well we'll do the poll
um where everyone gets on my case about
a whole video on them
uh
disappeared and kill okay well
everyone's just saying the comments
um
or doing a whole video uh that's true
nuke
um
about doing the whole video on some
obscure thing I will say I did a whole
video on the Obscure Stone worms and
that ended up being a treasure Trove of
lore though there was more to go off of
for that
um and we even got the effects for Life
thing we uh renamed so there there's a
lot okay disappear has a hundred percent
so we're gonna disappear
go away
okay it felt like they had a little bit
more ethereal stuff going on
um
you don't even know their name facts
well everyone's I still get comments
every day same people I call them Stone
worms I'm still calling them Stone worms
and like 15 other little nicknames they
have for them
um
oh okay I see what you're saying James
yeah I get the meme
you should really get to the king bass
bass based I really gotta just actually
you know what's funny
um speaking of all of that I probably
won't well actually that could be a good
way to put it into the video the the
video is going to be it's gonna have a
sponsor in it
um but it's ALS but the
the sponsor that it's going to be uh
you'll probably find funny if you watch
the video and you think of this
discussion I'll think about um the blue
ball thing being a way to connect the
sponsor
um
but yeah that's uh that's pretty funny
and you will see you will see you'll see
why it's funny later
um it's similar but it was more
pronounced and slow like the sound of
the Beatles feels more deliberate if
that makes sense I I see what you're
saying I was gonna say it felt more
[Music]
um
ethereal in a way more kind of
definitely a more prominent sound than
the sound for the
blue balls the electric orbs the Wisps
as they're properly called
I can guess the sponsor now
yeah I uh
if you've seen Elden ring creators or
just gaming creators uh there's about
like four sponsors that have everybody
do sponsorships or reach out to
everybody to do sponsorships
um so yeah a lot of times it isn't too
hard to guess between them
oh
yeah this one sounds definitely like
quieter more uh in the background though
you could uh
if you could hear that over the crab
smash
I will say
um probably every single YouTuber in the
world that is monetized uh
has like probably gotten an offer to do
raid Shadow Legends
um as a sponsor but have you
get an Elden ring creators do raid
before I don't know if I have uh
I would expect that they have just
because there's so many
um but I just can't immediately think of
a video where I'm like oh yeah Smoketown
did a raid video or Zeo storm did a raid
video they might have and I just might
not have seen it
um but yeah
well we the sound thing was definitely a
point of note that I didn't think of
before
um that'll be something I can at least
casually mention even if I don't make it
a big point in the video
um
there's also I guess you you could say
an interesting video could be done about
the Beatles
um
they are a pretty prominent thing in the
game
um that comes up in like every area in
the game world is there an area that
doesn't have any uh
any of the Beetles like does uh are
there no Beatles
I can't think of one off the top of my
head
and uh
I will listen to this one
go away
I don't get attacked
these ones not disappear
I definitely thought these ones
disappear
oh
there we go
foreign
yeah it seems like there's a little bit
more chime to it as well
like maybe they hit a couple more of the
Chimes in that one then uh
then in the uh wisp one
either lost or monk
um did like a single raid Shadow Legend
sponsor okay yeah I could see I don't I
don't watch I know
um
I want to say I know Monk and I know
lost but I haven't seen
um
I haven't seen most of the videos so I
know
was it raid or someone else I saw one
video lost it that was a really really
well done like well graphically animated
and like high production value a
sponsorship that could have been for
raid I don't remember who it was for
um I don't think it was raid but yeah I
could I guess I could see that thank you
so much for the lower discussion these
games oh the poor little monster people
got hunted down to poor little skeleton
people got hunted down
really when you play the
okay that message seems like it ties off
uh
uh but really when you play the
elfel has lots of beetles flying ones
what are the flying beetles
flying around I'm shooting lightning of
course ordering lore through does Luigi
have blue balls thank you yes
um also should I end the pole the poll
still going someone let me know it was
for nordvpn okay yeah there we go
thank you for the correction
do you know about the little munchkins
and Sakura with the hats in terms of
lore no I never actually looked into too
much lore in sekiro and I never I played
Tech hero but I didn't do that many
playthroughs of it I probably did like
one and a half I don't even know it was
it was really really fun
I forgot about the alpha beetles off to
the side Maybe
are like they hanging on walls or give
me something else to jog my memory
are you hacking I wouldn't call this
hacking
I don't think so
um
I'm just really good at dodging all the
enemies so I can dodge them and move
back into the into place where they were
gonna hit me
um faster than you can see it's like
SpongeBob in that one episode where they
were the
the superhero team and Squidward
Squidward was Krakatoa
are we sleeping on any creators content
theories
um
I've been sleeping as in like not giving
it enough due credit or
are using sleeping in another way
because I don't think anybody has done
any sort of lore or content on the the
Wisps or the blue balls as chat has so
fondly chosen to call them
it's called super light armor
and takes so much out of me that I uh I
have to Fat roll that's the give and
take of it you can dodge really well but
you have to Fat roll
little meals on roofs the roofs are out
of the way not really necessary to reach
pretty forgettable oh okay well I assume
I interacted with him but maybe I didn't
oh I never noticed that there was a
really big tree over there quite like
she doesn't get picked up by the
algorithm all that much
exactly in that way yes
um
I don't follow
do a video or has she talked about some
of this the the Wisps
I've seen some acrylic stuff um yeah she
doesn't do as much uh algorithm uh
gaming she just uh has her content out
there which is very respectable and
she's been doing this longer than
um almost any of us so
and has the extremely comprehensive
theories so oh
I don't think we're sleeping on quail
egg
um but if I'm like missing something
that somebody else did feel free to let
me know
I never noticed the big tree over there
as well I know there are Big Trees here
and that was a connection I was going to
make between here and the
consecrated snow field
um
that there are big trees and that's
where you find the ancestral followers
and the other uh
and the other
and the other wisps the subject of the
video
thanks smoosh Campbell smiley face
yeah I'm still not super following
um
did I
mentioned like lore creators then I
didn't mention clay lag or what the
what's the connection here
sadly gotta go all good hope you have a
good rest of your uh Sunday nuke do
thanks for stopping by for hopefully one
of more streams for the future but yeah
for one of the rare streams of this
Channel and hope the video comes out you
enjoy it
yeah have a good rest of your day
interesting that there are the real
animals here and the spirit versions of
the followers here
as just above you get the actual
followers
but then in the boss fight Arena you get
the spirit animals
you too yeah have a good one nuke
oh I got a gold Rune too
and the Gold Room two pretty
we went over it's like the one of the
finger Maiden ones
am I supposed to be still looking for a
finger Maiden right now
anger man can be found
I guess maybe some people get down here
before they meet Melena Melena for the
first time
um
I I know I would be pretty shocked if
they did really do 10 euros saying good
luck and uh cute I want to say fox Emoji
oh thank you thank you very much uh nuke
it's very very kind of you
um yeah and again hope you have a good
rest of your uh Sunday thank you very
much for supporting the stream and
channel
that very kind donation
well I think we've somewhat exhausted
this area uh maybe I could go explore
the boss fight and then head up to
consecrated snow field
um
let me just find uh I never went far
here so we'll go get the pillars over
here
and as we're going um if anybody has a
lore questions or any ideas about goatee
stuff in terms of the discussions feel
free maybe something more than just
Elton ring will be God of War or God of
War will be Elden ring
um since unless you play God of War then
I guess you can comment without spoilers
what are we killing or disappearing
um oh oh so okay the poll might still be
going if so I'm gonna I'm gonna put an
end to it
end poll why I have to manually do that
it's not like a one minute timer
thank you everyone for voting
um but Donnie we were voting on whether
to kill or disappear the uh scarabs
because I wanted to see if they made a
sound similar to the
wisps
can you fight from PS5 to Xbox like talk
about console Wars like which one's
better like invading oh
Oh you mean like an Elden ring can you
invade PS5 to Xbox
um I don't believe there's any cross
play
I know in like a lot of modern like FPS
and stuff there's cross play but to my
knowledge there's no cross play in the
lunar ring
I'm like 90 sure on that
um
no I'm no I think there's no there's no
way there would be cross-blade I
wouldn't have heard of it I think I
think I'm aware enough of the news of
this game
I'm gonna invade you for real I wish you
much luck invading me right now
but I'm also not on either PS5 or Xbox I
don't have a PS5 and I don't have a new
Xbox
I I haven't had an Xbox in the Xbox 360
which was
probably my favorite console because I
played it the most are informative years
my thoughts are that it'll be great if
God of War wins because that'll cause
the maximum amount of Screech and
molding honestly like there's tons of
the Elder Marine community and the from
soft community that I love but yeah I
would uh
I'd be I'd be possibly down for that too
and because Alden ring has gotten so
much
hype and positive that there would be
there would be a lot of contention about
that but some contention is always so it
can be definitely all right especially
since um
especially if it's it's like well
well-mannered contention like people
talking about why they think it should
have won based off merits and not just
getting triggered like uh like console
playing War kind of thing
I didn't know quail egg noodles game oh
creators pretty sure I checked out the
target largest oh okay were you so you
were just like asking for
recommendations then moose yeah I would
qualag has a very different style of
content than like me or small town like
I would say I'm relatively similar to
small town
um
V limit I'm kind of like I positioned
myself somewhat in between them
sometimes I don't have as funny or
enough as many gags as V limit or as
good of his gags and I don't have like
the length or overall like in-depthness
at least recently um a small town
um
so I think of myself as kind of in
between that
um and but but like with that we're all
like a little bit similar
um in a way there's some United in terms
of the presentation of content whereas
Quail lag definitely has a very
different way of going about it very
long form but then also very uh
very comprehensive and very thematic
very influence based
um got the big flow charts
um yeah I would recommend uh everyone
that I just said and there are more like
tarnish archaeologists was really good I
found so I'm glad to hear you
check them out
um for my vids and see how they do a lot
of really good
um
really good content
did I not like this
I didn't I saw the fire and I thought I
lit it
all right um do you have oh why do you
have an Xbox controller that's I have an
Xbox 360 controller
um as I said because the Xbox 360
probably my favorite controller
um favorite console because I played in
my formative years
um so when I switched to PC I got a
wired Xbox controller and I just used
that an Xbox 360 controller at that so
this isn't like an Xbox One controller
um an interesting idea I just thought
about the consecrated snow fields have
both isolating orbs blue balls and
dragon king soldiers which use ice
lightning yes that was
um I didn't bring it up so far in this
stream but that is a little note that I
made
um that I do I do plan on connecting in
the video the presence of Dragon King
soldiers here and then in the
consecrated snow field and how they
um
they and how they use ice lightning and
how I want to say they're one of the
weapons they drop or a spell or
something I forgot what it was
specifically but it's a frost and
lightning and that connection to the
Wisps is definitely gonna be something
bring up in the video
did any Dark Souls ever win game of the
year
um like a secular doesn't count as the
Dark Souls it's a soulsborne akiro
um I'm pretty sure that got a game of
the game of the year maybe at uh uh
the game awards I want to say was that
the game awards I'm sure I got plenty of
other game of the years as well
um I'm sure some Publications must have
given game of the years to Dark Souls
one
two three bloodborne I assume they all
won at least one game of the year award
somewhere
um even with the Dark Souls 2 hate I bet
there was some publication that was like
really liked it
um let's catch up a little bit I always
forgot that I owned an Xbox one I played
for like seven hours total then I
returned on had my series X since last
June and still in the box whoa
um
that's some serious lack of play on the
consoles but uh I have PlayStation 4 and
I've ended up getting a good amount of
play time out of it for single player
games I played bloodborne
um
very very late I played God of War just
this past week so that's very very late
as well
um smoke time really do be on that
hustle for real for real very much uh
it's it's impressive to see like the
amount and the quality of content he can
put out definitely intimidating
um
since I'm somebody who's in my pastor
videos have been somewhat similar but
definitely for the DLC I do want to get
back a little bit into the longer form
comprehensive videos that go into the
big lore things
um like the main the main bosses and
some of the main aspects I kind of fell
off doing that
um for the main game after radagon and
radon but I will get back into that a
little bit definitely since I do like
the small Niche things but I also really
really like covering the big bosses as
well
um thanks sorry if I derailed you not
moose Campbell you're chill this is a
very chill stream
um running around doing lore so you're
good with the consecrated snow field
underground at some point or is gold and
lightning Source from the view of the
urge tree snow fields is hidden
so that could be
um there was I forget who in the
subreddit maybe it was
oh I forget rubato
um which is the one channel I linked
like the red scholar or Tess Lobo or
test Robo I'm forgetting his name
um but pointed out that or point out to
me when I was talking about it that the
line here you see the outline
fits really well into the
outline up here here
if you overlay the images
um they oh well you can't see it if you
go overlay the image of like the cracks
and the Mountainside right here it goes
well and maybe this is something we've
been covered a lot before it goes well
well with the same in here so maybe you
could say it slid down but then also
it's like slid down and moved a thousand
miles south so
the retief is that
what what is what
um okay let's let's catch up a little
bit you're on PC yeah I'm on PC
well on PS5 I can invade you on PC
is that true can you invade PC from PS5
Souls born Akira rang based Kojima one
director and then Sakura one goty I
believe that unironically love Dark
Souls to accept its flaws if I like its
lower deviations beautiful mess that's a
similar thing I get
um
I get people saying from Dark Souls 2
they they despite the issues they like
it I definitely like it a lot too
um does have does have some strong
issues
um Dark Souls 2 was better review than
both the other two games just in
community discussion over time this can
more heavily criticize Dark Souls 2 has
better reviews than like Dark Souls 1
and Dark Souls 3.
um that could be true uh I don't know
like say their Metacritic sores
um but I'd be I'd be pretty surprised if
that was the case
brought a gun is my favorite boss right
on solid it's worthwhile to do new game
plus you get new items good Crusader hey
um you I don't are there any new items
in New Game Plus because you can get
duplicates of items like you can get two
of these greatswords that's something I
got new game plus
um
you get all the talismans in new game
that was something that was kind of
disappointing when I played through the
game and I was getting plus ones and
plus twos in the new game uh I was I was
sad I said I'm like oh I'm not gonna get
these New Game Plus or is New Game Plus
gonna have fours and fives and then they
didn't that was too bad
um I always thought two was better so I
was kind of surprised when I found out
most fans didn't like it you thought two
was better than one and three uh Donnie
I would make tons of long-form videos
because as Grace Motown is I do not
speak Irish well
what is what
wait okay you both said WTF
is is that whoa
um are you just responding to the
comment
um yeah also John uh I'm pretty sure
small town is not Irish or Welsh
um and yeah he's speaking English but uh
I don't think he's either of those two
things
um
Walter White America's not understanding
accents even they are also English it's
always funny like I understand people
not understanding accents just in
general like plenty of people and
speaking certain
English in some places don't understand
anywhere
um that said I think I always didn't
have too tough a time understanding
languages not understand languages I'm
I'm super monolingual since I'm American
uh I have a super tough time
understanding languages I was always
pretty okay with accents um like one
time I had a French teacher in college a
math teacher who had a thick French
accent and my friend had a lot of
trouble with it but I was uh pretty
chill
um es2 has the highest Metacritic store
wow that's that's pretty uh pretty
surprising
um but interesting
um I definitely think Dark Souls 1 is uh
I'm gonna turn the audio down on this
um sound effects
I definitely think that Dark Souls 1 is
better than Dark Souls 2 and I play Dark
Souls 3 a lot more than Dark Souls 2 or
Dark Souls 1 so I'm probably biased
there and can't give a super good uh
was going whoa when you're talking about
oh shapes on the map oh cool I'm glad
that's like uh yeah it was if you see
the images lined up and maybe a
community post I'll mention it
um oh I was gonna make a community post
about this stream
um
that was kind of late to do that
um I don't know how long how long I've
been streaming
I don't see it
um
oh well
uh no it's fine this doesn't have to I
will make a community posts next time I
stream I'll make a community posts next
time I stream if any of you are here
remind me to make a community post
um
but yeah I didn't play uh Dark Souls 2
as much as three
um I'm assuming that's where my train of
thought was
if not oh well uh but
yeah
um I'm surprised has the highest
Medicaid score but then I'm assuming
bloodborne and secure both have higher
Metacritic scores and then and then I
guess Elden ring now I feel like Elden
ring was better reviewed than most of
the other games
um so I want to say I'm assuming it has
a higher Metacritic as well
some items require you play twice like
Millicent's Quest oh true if you want to
get all of the items in the game
um yeah I didn't think about that since
it's a different crest quest reward
um and I forget specifically about the
items but it might be the same as the
Jaron Selen questline
um you might need to do it twice uh to
get all the items
you should get banned from YouTube If
people that hack games get banned from
YouTube it'd be a pretty uh pretty sad
day on YouTube
um
even like uh Inferno plus made a whole
like series about like hacked Halo Dark
Souls if you guys haven't seen that
that's pretty goofy and if you like dark
souls or Halo I recommend checking it
out I'm pretty sure that was by Inferno
Plus
a new seven languages studied French
from grade three through the end of
college and then boom once I graduated
completely forgot oof
um
yeah I know language is definitely um is
hard to keep up if you don't have an
Avenue to practice them but that's a
pretty intense
early days of Dark Souls 2 online were
Golden Age The Running attacks Ultra
great swords would golf swing golf swing
people sending them flying
I I think I remember people talking
about
um Dark Souls 2 PVP being really lit
like a lot of the community I think
really liked it um like had a lot of fun
with the PVP but I uh
I play Dark Souls 2 way too late
and I think it was online but I played
it way too late to have a significant
PVP experience and I don't PVP that much
in general
I'd respect this Great Divine sacred
gentle God dear a lot more if you
weren't a POS attacking me well you do
invade his place
um
the music to this fight I know I have
another soundtrack playing but the music
to this fight is one of my uh as I said
my ranking video just a supremely
amazing soundtrack and I don't have it
too loud right now
all right um I was gonna I came in here
not to have an actual fight but see if
there's any more significant lore but uh
I don't really think there is like I can
kill him
he and he's a little too fiery to be
like the lightning of the Wisps I could
make some connection with just the blue
particle effects but
whatever and I this damage is not
hacking this is just uh
this is just
a lot of damage on a squishy boss
there he goes
a little late but I love how directed
distracted by Exodus are one second
she'll prove in like seven ways that
Renault was an OG was the OG well my
queen and then move on like it was
nothing
um yeah it definitely jumps around a lot
but um yeah and that can definitely be a
plus that she's able to cover so many
things and look at so many different
things uh
and their connections
really wish I could have had the
bloodborne Dash would have looked so rad
I think uh I'm pretty sure there's a mod
or a hack
not a hack a mod
um that gives bloodborne Dash I want to
say there's one that that makes uh light
roll maybe set hero Dash and medium roll
uh bloodborne Dash or something like
that or maybe make this bloodborne Dash
in your normal roll your backs up
bloodborne Dash and your normal roll
um your
uh
secular Dash
I checked in both secure and bloodborne
have lower scores than DS2 my gosh all
right you know I'm gonna I'm gonna fact
check I'm gonna fact check your fact
check right now
I was gonna do it on my phone so I
didn't have to alt tab but I don't think
I have my phone with me so I think I
have to all tab
all right we're gonna all tab all right
BRB everybody checking Metacritic
Metacritic
PS2
all right
um
and there's all the different platforms
and Scholar the person all right Dark
Souls 2 on PC has a 91. that's pretty
good
bloodborne bloodborne has a 92.
so should I be looking at Dark Souls 2
on like PlayStation 4 or something uh or
the PlayStation 3 sorry
um what about Dark Souls one
yeah Dark Souls has a 89 yeah that's
lower
and then Securo is a 90. wow impressive
to 91 on Xbox one but
I'm uh I'm pretty I'm pretty surprised
by that 91 yeah
so like for the most part you're you're
true
most part you're right
or two yeah 92 secular 90 bloodborne
anyone
PlayStation scores of the default Canon
ones is that just because from soft is
Japanese and
they're more big on actually making the
console games and a lot of times the PCS
are report
first time watching a quail like video
so far then because I'll make connection
running things while listening issues
for topics yeah you can see that being
uh tougher to
stick with but yeah if you like the
videos
um they have a ton of information in
them which is really cool
I think that bloodborne is a bit
overrated still good though
you know what
I might agree with you just for the fact
that people talk about bloodborne like
uh like it's like it's just the The God
video game
um it is really fantastic
um I just didn't connect it with it um
as much as a lot of the community did
since a lot of the community puts
bloodborne as the number one uh Soul's
like and I don't I don't think I would
put as mine I also played it really late
I played a lot of the games late but I
played ever game late except for Dark
Souls 3
I guess sekiro
and Eldon right obviously
um
all right well we're in the consecrated
snow field
there are a lot of these uh
a lot of the tree stumps probably maybe
part of why it's consecrated it's a
connection with the ancestral Woods
um one question does uh I remember
seeing this when the game first came out
and there were lots of messages about it
I'm sure there still are on multiplayer
does anybody know what this uh
this light is
is that ever a thing that was determined
bloodborne is honestly goat game but I
just hate everything about on Twitter
guaranteed 90 of people talk about it on
Twitter I've never played it and they
just pretend
like when liking bloodborne is your
personality
bloodborne is the best soulsborne game
but it ain't the second coming craziest
like people act like it is yeah I can I
can definitely um respect people having
it as their favorite or thinking just
it's the best uh out of the bunch
I don't have a strong opinion on what I
think is my favorite
Dark Souls one
World design I give a ton of credit for
her
secular for being the most polished
combat experience obviously sacrifices a
lot and it's being like not having the
varied weapons and uh stats like every
uh one of the other games
you can be a fan of the game even if you
haven't played it like you can I guess
acknowledge and respect things it's done
but yeah it's weird to say you like like
it even if you've never played it when
like playing it it's like saying you
like Mona Lisa if you've never seen Mona
Lisa
um obviously it's not as much of an
investment to go see Mona Lisa as it is
to play through a whole video game
um but it's still kind of odd to not
experience it in the way it's intended
to be experienced talk about it
like bloodborne but these three is the
best bosses I do really like the series
bosses and was kind of disappointed
overall with the bosses in Elden ring
um Dark Souls 3 was easy compared to
Dark Souls 2. I played Dark Souls 2
after so I can't speak for certain
um
I play Dark Souls one
first and then Dark Souls 3
um and I just I felt equipped enough
from Dark Souls 1 to play Dark Souls 3
and like be like felt like a I
understood Souls games the souls like
combat experience roughly
um and I think that's still held true
um but then obviously I was more
equipped when I did Dark Souls 3 but
more Dark Souls 2 and the other ones as
well
I hope it never comes to PC and those
people keep seeding forever be a Twitter
side but everyone was the first game
that really made me spend hundreds of
hours thinking about Laura that's that's
really cool and one of the one of my
first big lore aspects was uh getting
into lore with
um vati videos on bloodborne for sure
just I guess on the from soft games in
general I would see lore videos about
like say Fallout from the nth Apple
um which now I guess more of the front
soft community community might know um
because of the
uh bat with Eridan
um
I think there was another I don't know I
did lore videos on Fallout before I did
four videos on any of the from soft
games
like the verticality and traversal of
Dark Souls ones world like the
individual area design Dark Souls 2
Gameplay OST of DS3 the deepest lore of
Elven ring
do you think Elden ring has the deepest
lore maybe because it's the most like
significantly built up a world in a
single game
um or has the most obscure things
um bloodborne is my favorite but I'm a
big fan of Lovecraft I'd love to see
more like that but not a sequel
I would probably be well if from soft
made a sequel I would play it and I'm
sure I would enjoy it but in terms of
another similar game but different kind
of Universe versus sequel yeah I don't
know which I prefer I recently
um
oh got the knightkins dragonkins I keep
calling the Duncans
um
the uh Lovecraft uh I've been reading a
collected works book on Lovecraft and
I've been uh quite enjoying it saved for
his uh cat name that comes up in at
least one of his stories uh that I just
read
everything about its themes was tailored
to my taste and interest secret
intelligent areas called universities
ritual sacrifice of kids by Elites
Eldritch Gods yeah if a game really
connects with your preferred themes
um in addition to being just a really
good game overall yeah that's gonna
that's gonna definitely leave a lot of
pluses for you
thank you
yeah because of the open world for the
deepest lore or no yeah because of the
open world or Elden writing peepstor I'm
assuming that's what you mean Ellen
Rings single game lore is almost on par
with the entirety of I'm assuming you're
gonna be talking about uh
the entirety of the Dark Souls games
Dark Souls one two and three
um I feel like because those are
different lands you say there's enough
there's enough distinct lore that it's
more than Eldon ring um even if Elton
ring is a lot bigger but I also
have that's completely got there's no
quantification to that
all right maybe I should make this a
challenge and actually turn off my uh
invincibility
lovecraft's cat is a shadow that lingers
over every conversation about him
oh yeah I guess a little bit
um
could just be a thing about like
the racism in general
um for him which isn't like that
surprising given he was like a new
englandite from the 19th like 1900
um but I also like the last story I read
in the book like just the most recent
one I read was the first time that he
featured a character cat that was named
after his cat so I knew of the cab but I
just had that in my memory
um
just recently
Elden ring is the most historical of
them all for sure because videos do a
good job of covering why yeah I can
definitely
um see that I saw one of the videos
where she was talking about like the
corresponding ages of the things in game
um
and with the George RR Martin doing the
history
um there's definitely it gets an aspect
of that
more so than otherwise also uh I don't
remember did you guys ever die
or do I I might just like killing ghosts
for no reason
Nike can still got some fault in you
um
you know I haven't played a Fallout in
so long I forgot what the night can are
they uh are they a creature they're a
kind of guy
you gotta you gotta remind me smoking
Sakura is in need of sequel after that
true ending
um yeah to get nothing after sekiro like
I respect making the game putting out
and being fine with it but then no DLC
or anything that was it was tough
um
sheer quantity of yours lore is almost
on par with the entirety of Elder
Scrolls which is crazy
I've never gotten too much into Elder
Scrolls lore but I I I feel like that's
contentious because they have like a
whole they got a whole well I guess you
could call the planes between a whole
continent but the continent the
different peoples in Elden ring I not in
Elder ring and uh
the Elder Scrolls two Elders
um
and they're very developed history I
want to say I wouldn't I wouldn't think
that's true these clouds are really
freaking out here
um
but I'm not enough of an elder spring
Elder Ring's Elder
I can't speak Elder Elders Rings Elder
Scrolls head to know that I played a ton
of Skyrim but I actually haven't played
any of the other any of the other games
um hi says Mateo hello Mateo
um they're the blue super mutants from
New Vegas
okay
okay yeah yeah I didn't
I didn't play as much a bit New Vegas as
I did three and four
um but I did play it uh and those rang a
bit of a bell but yeah for some reason
the past like when I was thinking about
the dragonkins
um I was like thinking about this video
and then doing the stream I
kept calling them nightkins like in my
head
um which was weird Elder string yeah I
was uh my speech is done
as I uh haven't done much uh
I haven't done much streaming and I've
basically just been non-stop talking
which I guess as a streamer I should
learn to let there be dead air like
that's okay
um
but yeah
I'm running up to my limit of ability of
speech
yeah it's similar this this could be a
good area to point out um the similar
sound because I can go from one to the
other
all right let's catch up on some
listen to the audiobook of the rats yeah
the rats in the walls and got jump
scared by the narrator introducing the
cat yeah good Crusader that's that's the
story I just read which was a really
good story I enjoyed it I basically
every single one I've one of the stories
I've read I've liked a good amount even
when people I looked up reviews and
people like yeah this is one of the bad
stories
um like poor quality but I still enjoy
it
um but yeah I just read rats in the
walls and that was the
the N word cat character
someone mention secures trending earlier
I gotta say the purification ending
actually made me cry the cinematics in
the game were so well done oh that's
super cool I had that uh connection
I covered the high in the same way that
from tried the open world thing Elden
ring and knocked out of the park they
did the same with cinematics and
psychiro yeah the the more focused
narrative and Sakura I thought was done
really well
um I guess it'd be interesting you could
in terms of comparisons since Elden ring
and God of War are gonna get compared a
lot maybe it'd be better to compare
um sakuro with God of War maybe you
compare it with the first one as opposed
to this new one since it's not as new of
a game
um but since sekiro is a much more
secure probably has a lot more similar
similarities and a lot more points for
fair comparison
um than something like Elden ring does
at least if it's God of War Ragnarok is
a quote-unquote open world in the same
way
um that God of War 2018 was since it's
not really an open world
um and it's
much more like a linear narrative to me
um than it is in open world like Ellen
ring and Alden ring lacks the linear
narrative like sekiro
what are your thoughts on Elden ring
bosses from either of my favorite after
psychos
um if you saw my boss remembrance
ranking video
um I'm actually relatively critical I
didn't enjoy them as much as like Dark
Souls 3 bosses
for the most part
um really triggered by the eldenbeast I
need to fight malikith more
um not the biggest fan of him morgot has
some issues but I there are some aspects
I really like godric I like
um I don't know if there are any bosses
in this game that I like as much as say
Abyss watchers from Dark Souls 3.
I really really really like
um
like the abyss Watchers
um I thought they were a really really
well done Duo multi party fight
um
so yeah gonna be hard to or just Gwen
soul of Cinder
um
I don't know if I'm gonna have like a
favorite boss fight from Elden ring in
my like top whatever of the whole series
um
yeah
your bids are so helpful for the lore of
this game oh thank you very much uh
Chuck I am glad to hear that
let's see let's catch up I can start a
hero before the first fight with
kenichuro Kuro nervously steps up to
guinichiro and wolf puts his arm out in
front of him and starts fighting then at
the end except teenager of um curl puts
his arm out in front of wolf to stop him
and starts talking shows as much he
grows so well then yeah it's uh and with
the cycles of rebirth and whatnot that's
a
um a very good little Point narrative
point
dream cycle or Randolph Carter's here is
my favorite bloodcraft's work I think
there's a lot of good stuff to build
fantasy worlds off of yet
um I don't know if the dream cycle is
the title of a work but in some of the
stories I forget which one it was
um
I don't think it was Randolph Carter um
but he talks about like the dream world
kind of like entering into it and like
um the descriptions he gives of that of
it being Fantastical and multi-colored
and like super super
just fantasy
um were really evocative and yeah really
like seeing that in a game or something
would be really really cool
um soundtrack based disappointing
certain bosses not the quality I was
expecting yeah um I probably had a
relatively similar experience radagon
sort of reminds me of Soul of Cinder and
Gwen yes I agree
um which is why the Eldon Beast is so
difficult because it like takes what you
could see being something similar to
those other one those other boss fights
that like rank super highly for me
um
and instead of the eldenbeast maybe we
could have had something that like
brings radagon into that same level but
if you like Lovecraft you should really
read Edgar Allan Poe I should um I don't
know if I've I might have read one poem
by Edgar Allan Poe um I think my and my
sister loves him
um
but I should read a grandpa after I
finish this Lovecraft book maybe that'll
be my next uh
my next so my next work of spooky horror
um late 1800s early 1900s things
um find it hard to even consider Elden
ring open world seems more like stalker
to me open level after open level it
doesn't help that Elden ring area by
area is organized in a linear fashion
that's fair
um I that stalker is a game I need to
play before stalker 2 comes out I think
it's soccer too that's the one coming
out right
um
uh but yeah that's a that's a fair point
since it's not
the the levels don't connect in the same
way as say
um to be fair Dark Souls 1 was in
um
open world but it had a like a different
kind of connection between the levels
um
but uh yeah I don't know
I would still consider an open world
game because you can go around anywhere
and there are big sections but it is
pretty fair to call
um a lot of the progression between air
oh open levels
um somewhat linear
when I got to the final Gauntlet of
malachath Gideon Godfrey radagon
eldenbeast I knew I wouldn't have a hard
time with him so my challenge became
killing them without dying
oh I was so op by the end of the game
that I one shot all in-game fights other
than the fire giant even Melania I just
steamrolled her blind on my first
attempt oh yeah if you're you're just
using you just made a build and uh
running through it yeah you can
definitely uh especially like sword of
Knight and fire in the game first
released
was smoking bosses especially if you did
it with a mimic tear
um dream cycle is the question of his
Works about the dreamlands mostly
featuring Randolph Carter as the MC okay
well then maybe that's what I'm thinking
of
um
I'm assuming since the Dreamland sounds
like what I would be thinking of in
terms of a description but I don't
remember what they were called or what
the story I read was called so I'm gonna
assume it's that uh
and I'll look into that
I hate to admit it but I like the
eldenbees hey if you if you liked it
that's you're you're allowed to like
what you like and it's even it's not
it's not a bad thing to like it um
if you want to like come at me and be
like it was epic epically designed
um or even it's not even that it's a
because the aspects there are aspects in
which the album beast fight is really
cool like it definitely has really cool
thematics the spectacle the Grandeur of
the OST
um the visual design
and those are all things you can like
they can
suit your tastes or not
um and that can be fine
um since you can like appreciate those
aspects more than the other ones and
that can make it a thing that you like
it's just amount of like what you give
weight to and that's just gonna depend
um by the person so it's very much not a
problem if you like it I'll all disagree
that it's like well designed in terms of
a gameplay experience connecting with
the thematics but
um don't let anyone ever tell you that
you can't like
um a boss or a game or whatever
because that's what that's what the
whole discussion with Dark Souls 2
um
and we saw it here before uh has the
highest Metacritic
um
or one of the highest uh but it's uh
which is what you like and the whole
point of games or one of the whole
points of games is to enjoy and be
entertained by it so more power to that
let's see element Beast was a huge
letdown in terms of boss fight yeah I
I was quite let down by the Olympics
personally
elimis I realized to pull out all the
stops
to avoid dying it's the only time I'd
use these poison brain items heal myself
so it's very yeah that's cool
um
it's cool that you had that experience
with it being difficult
um or too easy but then like turning
that into something that you could still
enjoy so good job uh on that
these guys are massive
yep Edgar Parnell that's definitely a
theory I've never seen before yeah
um
I think Albany is one of the best balls
from oh
strong opinion
sure he run a lot but also my dear and
we love that fight uh yes I'm a deer
um I don't remember the meteor fight
enough uh to say but just the experience
at least for me of playing eldenbeast
um wasn't enjoyable because there was so
much downtime because I don't know it
just like also I'm somebody who really
likes uh
the person like the person what do you
say humanoid fights in these games those
are generally my favorite like I really
like the abyss Watchers soul of Cinder
Gwen
um and they don't have to be person like
humanoid and periable in the sense of
like a PVP
um character or like an Invader
um but soul of Cinder very much not that
that's all the cinder um
Eldon Beast is very much not that that
plus it's running away
um
and just really not it doesn't feel like
you're on a similar pudding which feels
like sometimes the most fun fights like
you've grown and developed and such a
strong character even if this is some
god-like entity you're killing it so
you're you should be on somewhat similar
standing
um and the elderly's fight how it was
designed really didn't make me feel that
way
all right let's let's run some ketchup
everybody all right
um Ellen Beast run a lot of Beast really
cool aesthetically but there was a fight
it's really boring yeah that's I agree
with that
um I think just happened to be perfect
weird build perfect for the Beast yeah
that can definitely um increase your
enjoyment with it
people that had really fast builds with
summons and high Health had way better
first runs with the game people who
ended up super heavy weapons or faith
especially when the game first came out
um I think since then they've had a
couple rounds of Buffs for heavy items
or heavy weapons that made them um
more enjoyable to use probably a little
bit stronger but also like
um
more versatile a little bit quicker
um so it's not as crazy slow heavy and
you're not has and you don't have
um quite the same
the same limited number of options
um in terms of which attacks you can use
for which openings
um anyone hyped as much as me over
dadable Ragnarok a lot well you saw I
don't know if you saw any of the reviews
it's getting really good reviews it's
getting really hyped I thought it was
coming out on PC I don't know how I was
so hyped that it would come out on PC
and then I found out and it didn't and I
was I was so upset
um I might get it for the PlayStation 4
because I don't have a PS5
but I was so upset I found out it wasn't
coming out for the uh PC I was so ready
to play it on PC because I played the
other one on my PlayStation 4.
um and it was on a not so great screen
so I'm like oh I was gonna be on PC the
graphics are gonna be tight and I'm sad
I'd be the fire giant level 78 I want to
say that's pretty low
it feels low
yeah I'm gonna say it feels low
last ball should have just given radagon
a second phase I enjoyed fighting
radagon once I figured him out but I
felt eldenbees was a cheap shot at
Grandeur
um I enjoyed El uh radagon more
um as I fought him Eldon Beast
well I got really mad when I would like
die to one hit
um
for the album Beast or when I was like
low or something um when I didn't know
him or it's for sure but I don't know if
I like it that much more even if I do
know the kit for the most part
um
ER was written by George RR Martin it's
like nice yes
um I'm looking forward to playing
Ragnarok Tuesday night yeah
um I'm probably gonna get it and yeah it
should be a really fun game the first
one was really fun um even if I do have
like some issues with it
I think media worked because it was very
long and epic fight when Eldon Beast is
both a very long and slow paced fight
you can feel mind-numbing that plus it's
a second phase fight so you have to go
through radagon first to do so kind of
just like Mars my experience with
radagon
um which Madeira was solo did have a
somewhat annoying Boss run back for a
super high Health boss but C'est la vid
I didn't move on to any new area until I
Scout every inch of the area so I was
super super high level by the time I got
the end game yeah that's gonna
um
I've heard some people doing that and
getting pretty over leveled
um which is understandable and I don't
think a too big of an issue in the sense
of could Mars some people's first
playthroughs
um but the overall expectation I think
um for most people is that they're not
gonna go crazy
um exploring everything first
playthrough
um or just like ever most people aren't
gonna explore every inch of the world
um so I think it's okay to
let that be like if you do that you
might get very overleveled but I'm
really glad to hear that even though you
uh
um
did get over leveled you still found a
way to enjoy the fights the self-imposed
handicap
I didn't get much lore from these guys
um they're the trees and they're the red
petals or flowers
um
but past that there's not much distinct
here there's the horn Bud that I picked
up from this
um in terms of lore about the Wisps
since this is a stream technically
somewhat about lore
um
is PS5 still rare it might be I just
haven't tried getting a PS5 and I didn't
want to get it just for this one game
um since I only just played the other
God of War
I recommend Angel of the past bit about
Elden Ring's story I'm sure y'all check
it out I don't think I've heard of Angel
of the past
um
surprisingly good against the Elton bees
as long as you can get them
let me hold still okay
I thought yeah I saw somebody use
Loretta's uh arrow on the right of his
bow whatever the spell is called
um during the against the other beast
when it was flying and I think it was
like a speed run so they were probably
super strong but it seemed like a
effective tool to bring it back down
um
it's rare but they're supposed to be
increased in stock for ragnarok's
release right now A friend of mine just
got his for instance today yeah and I
heard about people getting
um
the like yotun version of the PS5
um for Ragnarok so I'm assuming that
means there's just a
there's a God of War PS5 so
new stock for that for the game release
um and I think to create like shatter
more okay I am caught up and you guys
are just chit chatting about George's
contributions to the game
um but yeah you guys are covering it
pretty well that I'm
don't need a super answer that he did do
uh
a lot of like World building but then
the story after the World building was
left up to left up to from Salt
oh
I was uh someone hoping that there would
be something a little bit more in these
these trees are pretty massive uh white
trees
um I don't know if any in the
consecrated not the con I mean the
conscripted snow field if any in the uh
ancestral Woods area
was as big as like this one for instance
oh
well we'll be interesting it'll be
interesting to see all the discussion
that comes out
um around god of war and
go to your discussions
um I guess for the next month as the
game comes out uh releases this week and
then we have the game awards
then we have the game awards um next
month yeah it should be interesting I'm
thinking about
um if I do play the game I might make a
video of comparison with it in Eldon
ring
um I probably I won't try to compare the
entirety of the games but I'll try to
focus in on a couple of points um if I
do do that because I don't think I'd
want to make a God of War Standalone
video but I'd be happy to contribute to
the discussion of it and Eldon ring um
since probably most of the discussion is
going to be
mediocre at least as so far as what I've
seen just like random internet
commenters I'm just playing more on each
other about which game is going to be
better
her the Ragnarok had a really bad ending
hope it's not true
oh yeah I hope that's not true too
um I heard that it's supposed to be
um that they're not going to do a
Trilogy that people excited trilogy but
it's not gonna be a Trilogy
um
if so I'd be happy I'd be interested to
see how the story finishes out but
there's plenty of story to cover with
Ragnarok the end of the world
um and like all the other Norse gods so
we'll see we'll see
Game of Thrones mystical trees oh
actually yeah this uh
this area is uh pretty similar to the I
I watched Game of Thrones I haven't read
any of the Song of Ice and Fire
um but the the white trees with the red
petals
um these are like the the old
the old old gods trees in the north
right the weird words Weir Woods
um
is there any name or something I'm
missing like the red
I think the red was on the on the tops
of the trees
um and they were like kind of weepy
weeping willow-esque trees
um
I couldn't seem to kill the disappearing
gargoyle in this area
well I wasn't able to kill the
um the dragon cans I don't know if you
can though what is the disappearing
gargoyle also uh
a spirit like them like the dragon kids
oh yeah true if anybody um spoils
anything about
God of War you're getting nuked from the
channel I promise you that
um just because
doesn't do anything to uh benefit
anybody it's just ruin ruin people's
times if so yeah we'll see we'll see
what it is um discussion wise
and the books are called the nameless
Woods okay
um
but in
I'm assuming the
the show didn't change the name
um
of the trees like sometimes like the
white trees with the red are called uh
dragon sorry
oh okay yeah yeah no um
why I was fighting them moose and I also
didn't kill them so
I forget if there's a way to kill them
or not
um well you can spoil the game if
somebody like if there were leaks or
something for example that would be the
spoil
um
but are these called
Weir Woods
the and like the one they have in in
Winterfell they've won in the center of
the city
um it's the old religion
uh
anyone anyone got me this one
one day you see God of War Games set in
Egypt yeah they well in the first one
um they did point to like the other
religions
um have a tear walked around yellowed
around the world and they they point out
Egypt pretty strongly so that could
definitely be if they make this into
God of War Assassin's Creed
um and they go around the world and they
just have Infinity games they could
definitely do one in Egypt
yeah the part of the Gods
all right
um I think we're doing pretty good
um we explored the areas I was going to
in terms of lore uh
I don't know if there's really anything
else in game
um to like find I've looked at item
descriptions for most of the ancestor
stuff
um talk about rebirth life death and the
eritry and out of the air tree the old
way of doing things
um
there's all connections to the the
lightning lightning orbs the blue balls
the Wisps
um
but yeah and then it's just these two
these two areas are the only ones only
areas in game where you find them I was
surprised I didn't super remember that
you found some of the Wisps farther away
from these Woods I think you can find
some of them along the Rocks over here I
will say this does remind me a little
bit of Skyrim
um just the style of the snow and the
the rocks
and the openness of it
um
climbing some mountains in Skyrim if you
see that you can go to it
um
but yeah I think that'll
um
oh this guy I didn't know there was a
group of nobles here this guy is uh has
the Mad Luigi hat
I guess I could just say Luigi hat but
um but yeah I don't think I'm gonna do
another game I recently got Call of Duty
um and I could uh could stream that a
little bit I saw zeostorm streaming Call
of Duty over on Twitch
um
thank you
but I think for now just some Elden ring
streaming is fine golden rune 13.
that seems high for I guess I know we're
in late game but uh
yeah 13.
the grace of gold bust those who were
first to serve it the most Vivid
coloration
well I'm pretty pretty weak dude to be
holding a 10 000 Rune
um Rune on him I guess
um
Edgar you see you seem to be asking
random questions
just saying
here I see this guy is the Hat I farmed
one of these guys and um
in
Lim grave
for hours trying to get this hat
wait no you probably got it from the
chest I got one for What from the chest
is there chest here
are they supposed to be like carrying a
chest don't they normally just walk
around
one other open world game with ambient
Ambiance as good as Skyrims or all the
crap people give uh the fall the
Bethesda games uh they do have an
amazing like atmosphere Ambiance at
least well I I really love Skyrim so
uncontroversial opinion
um but yeah well we'll see with uh
TS6 because that's coming out
and not like five more years from now
it'll be here in in December no sad sad
no
no Skyrim sequel
um I've been seeing a Theory online
that's here's the Eldon Beast was the
first form of life to exist lines
between hence the monocellular creature
kind of look yeah that wouldn't be uh
too surprising or that it came around or
in part of the uh greater Wills
quote-unquote creation of Life of it
splitting things
um
or splitting The Crucible or making The
Crucible turn
take form into individuated life
some areas you can find Nobles carrying
a chest with them that contains really
big Rune item I assume that's he got
such a big rude item from them oh
um
I know you can find the ones in the
Caravan
um but those normally have like weapons
right I don't feel like I've seen the
ones of them carrying a chest but that
would I didn't see it just here I'm
pretty sure I got this off a body
somebody can go back in the VOD if they
want to see
um but it could just be something along
the lines of that for sure
all right well I think we're gonna be
we're gonna be calling it around calling
it there everybody
um
talked about lore talked about the
goatee discussion a little bit
um there's not too much to talk about
the game's not out
um but just in terms of how to talk
about it I actually really like my
secure point I think it's a I think
that's a good point
um
how did God Godfrey obtain The Crucible
Knights
um maybe they just respected his uh
ancient ability to kill
I mean it's really funny if you kill
everyone around them they take the chest
and start booking it to get away from
you oh that's that is funny I feel like
I've never seen this
I don't think The Crucible is supposed
to be an actual thing
it's just you describe the nothingness
before the air tree
and what would you say to things having
like aspects of The Crucible like uh
Miss begotten or other creatures having
like
um things which
seem to resemble or be influenced by The
Crucible there's there's something to
that no I talked about it in one of my
videos how I feel like uh
like I laid out kind of my theory behind
it but like say I go to
Crucible scaled talisman
um
Talisman fashion from a scale that
embodies the aspects of various
creatures said to have grown on human
body long ago a Vestige of The Crucible
of primordial Life Born partially of
devolution it was considered a signifier
of the Divine in ancient times but is
now increasingly disdained as an
impurity as civilization has advanced
so yeah I don't know I it reads to me
that there's The Crucible primordial
life was something
um even if it's just like kind of an
earlier stage and the
um frenzy flame does seem really mad at
the greater will for bringing about
individuated life
um as opposed to what was before and it
has some attachment to what was before
that feels like more than just literal
pure nothingness
um at least that's that's my reading on
it
herb tree represents the golden order
seeking to establish its will Crucible
the chaotic world pre-ord tree I think
regardless of interpretation something
like that
um or some something like that would
exist in most interpretations have you
noticed that the map of Elden ring
reminds
the body of godwing Crucible was sacred
was sacred copy gay
The Crucible wasn't just a bunch of ugly
things cope is that an emote
um
I'm assuming it's some sort of tokimo
but golden order isn't way more based
and hotter golden order is cringe
because it like genocides and enslaves
excited to see when the Holocaust Bowl
actually is well maybe we'll have a
DLC going back in time to see The
Crucible I don't think that'll happen
but maybe
um
the map looks like the body of Godwin I
guess like is this the head
[Music]
I don't super see and the body is just
kind of like tripled like a shriveled
mermaid body is that that was supposed
to be
it is a Kobe em one yes okay can you see
the email since I just see cope GE
um or is it an email on Twitch that
you're just referencing here
I just don't know
the the map looks like a furled finger
oh yeah I can see the the finger
um okay I I think most of these
connections are a little bit strenuous
um but yeah I can kind of see why people
are bringing up
hello love your work question have you
changed your mind in any theories or
thought processes you've laid out in
one of your videos
um hey fine cop uh how you doing I don't
think no I don't see any emo it's just
twitch thing okay gotcha
have I changed any of my thoughts or
lower theories probably
I can't think of any specifically
um
I also didn't realize the time change
was happening today and it feels like
more than an hour later than it says it
is
um
things that I thought about or that have
think differently
um I know small town came out the video
saying the greater will isn't an outer
god
um I don't think I'm fully convinced of
that so I won't completely abandon my
previous videos talking about the uh
greater will as in our God though he's
I'm sure done more research on it than I
have
um he had the whole video and I haven't
had a video justifying why it is in our
God
I like there has to be at least one or
two examples because like I think I
remember thinking things and people
pointing stuff out later there have been
factual things like there are Lookout
stones in more areas than I referenced
in the video
um like more random areas
um since I referenced one area that
wasn't a ever
jail but there were more areas
um
I'm not sure
um if I think the ones all come up but
if there's any significant ones you
think oh your mind should have been
changed uh you let me know
this is when you travel back in time to
ooh seal so okay yeah that's true
um
not that I guess it's not as primordial
but it is in the past it's going to see
the the backstory
um of a significant happening
um so yeah it's not too impossible
though I guess with the what I talked
about in my Coliseum video
um
think
well no I think we could go to the past
but I guess if we did I would think it'd
be more to a time when the the herd tree
is popping and the golden order is
popping
um and like the costumes were happening
um as opposed to like the primordial
Life The Crucible but I don't I don't
have a strong
um feeling on it one way or the other so
I don't know but I think
oh I see I've been streaming for two
hours so that's pretty good I I just
finally found the timer I think that's
everything
um
and yeah
I think that's gonna we're gonna end the
stream there I hope you all have enjoyed
I think
I think I can share
um I recently started a Discord so I'm
going to share the link to that I'm not
a Discord Pro so uh don't expect much
but hopefully it should work and not
just uh have wrong permissions for
everybody so I will share that in the
chat right now let me uh just let me
just invite
uh
send a server link invite
copy all right
all right everybody I'm gonna I'm gonna
invite you in chat
I'm gonna try to I can find the chat
window
before you leave all right let's see the
air tree is just the wise tree that is
from over 25 year old only game that if
you have a PC you must try this game
what uh
um if you can reward reword that I'll do
another try before you leave do you
think this will probably happen DLC we
touched Michael's hand to God into his
dream but he started creating the hag
tree using its Pierce hat as a medium
then I got corrupted by most Omen blood
and the formless mother's influence that
is definitely a very uh some aspects of
that are a very popular running Theory
um so we might
um especially with the touching hand bit
um
it is a very
not apparent but just like a
strong I don't know what the word for it
is evocative uh thing to be a good
entrance to a DLC so that definitely
could happen um the Nikola dream is uh
is a strong one especially because
Michael is one of the most major
characters that we get Littlest about
um since Nicola is currently doing
nothing in the actual game
to me more shows a wise tree with those
scam ads and I keep seeing edits of the
tree's face in the air tree oh based
um been a pleasure all right okay I'm
gonna link this should be the Discord so
if you want to join feel free just to
chat I can announce videos there too
um chat about Elden ring about game
lore about philosophy game philosophy
like I didn't want my own video
um and just about stuff
um let's see
look like an object in older production
the map was just an island with a
gigantic circular crater in the middle
of the map still takes the same shape
yeah I wouldn't um think it's too uh
I don't think the shape has too much
bearing but it's always the development
versus lore hoo-ha stuff
to open the game awards they show us the
other ring DLC that would be really
based that'd be really cool
um if we get even sooner that'd be great
but yeah
um
and yeah I don't know how long it would
be when they announce it how long it
would be from release uh I really wanted
to be
if it could come out in the next like
three to four months DLC like release it
that would be fantastic
um since it's already been like we're
getting pretty long relative to the
other game releases in their DLCs
yeah that'd be great for corrupted dream
it could be similar to the Hunter's
nightmare from the old Hunters yeah it
could be
um well I think that's it everybody I
hope you have enjoyed uh my first stream
in a while if we get a
game awards maybe I'll stream that
um if they're okay with restreams
um maybe I'll stream sometime in the
sometime in the meantime if there's just
a separate announcement of the DLC I'll
probably stream that or stream an
analysis of that
um as opposed to doing a whole video on
it
um I should be releasing the lore video
that I mentioned in this uh
uh stream sometime this this week I want
to release it this week
um because I didn't release a video last
week
so look
uh be on the lookout for that be on the
hype for that and yeah thanks everybody
for watching thanks for your time hope
you have a good rest of your Sunday hope
it's chill hope it's nice hope you have
a good time
um yeah thanks for watching see you guys
later peace